Jamie Shapiro welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me welcome to
trigonometry
I'm Frances foster I'm constant and kiss
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of watching people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about at trigonometry we don't pretend
to be the experts we ask the experts
yeah the world-famous angel comedy club
our amazing expert guest this week is
Jeremy Shapiro who is the research
director for the European Council on
Foreign Relations and a former senior
official in the State Department under
President Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton Jamie Shapiro welcome to
trigonometry thanks for having me
[Music]
Jeremie superior thank you for coming on
thanks for having me
it's great to have you here so before we
get started with a was I into which I'm
sure will be lots about foreign foreign
affairs which is something you're an
expert in just tell us a little bit
about how you got to be where you are
today yeah it's a long and winding road
you know I grew up in in Boston and
Massachusetts in the u.s. in a very sort
of normal suburb and I had a sort of
staggeringly boring you know by the
standards of such things childhood I've
always wanted to have a sort of
childhood trauma to overcome but I never
managed to find one my my parents were
great they were always encouraging me we
you know we weren't neither too wealthy
nor too poor which is you know
frustrating to create a story but
probably very good for one's childhood
and the only real problem I had I think
as I was growing up was that I was very
I was very technical I was very and I
was a sort of computer nerd even before
it was popular to be a computer nerd and
I spent you know most of my teenage
years in college experience in the
computer lab and after university I got
a job in Silicon Valley working for a
big computer company which was pretty
good I suppose but I think over time I
became really very very bored with it it
had the problem that it was extremely
detailed oriented more than more than
about concepts and you got very very
good at smaller and smaller parts of the
computer project that you were working
on which was in the interest of the
company to make you a real expert at
something very small and as he got
better and better at less and less of
eventually yeah you were the sort of
world's expert at nothing and he was
very isolating you could only really
talk to the five or six people that you
worked with who were the last people
that you wanted to talk with because you
saw them all day and they were frankly
very boring so at that point in my
mid-20s I sort of wrote to a professor
that I'd had in University and said
you know I think I want to do something
else and he recommended that I come to
the school that he was at and get a
master's degree in international
relations which was at Johns Hopkins ice
in Washington DC and I did that and that
was really quite helpful for me to sort
of understand the role of politics came
a bit late to it but to understand the
role of politics in in life and to
understand what the big questions were
and I spent several years in a masters
in a ph.d program which I never
completed rest I see you're a dropout
that means you must be very good all the
dropouts always deal well right yeah I
think dropping out of a ph.d program is
a sort of badge of honor because because
it shows that you lack the patience to
wrestle with an idea for five or seven
years until you've beaten it to death
and no I mean I think I should have
graduated but I was I was afflicted by
the sort of twin enemies of knowledge
which are love and money and I and I
moved to Washington both for a job and
for a woman I eventually lost the woman
but I unfortunately managed to keep the
job really sure frankly that that was
the right choice but there it was and I
ended up working at at I started at Rand
which is a big think-tank which works
mostly for the US Defense Department in
Washington I sort of I think I did
something which is very which is very
helpful for anyone starting out which is
I I showed up as an intern and I just
refused to leave and so eventually they
gave me a job and you know that was
great I mean because you were really
sort of wrestling with policy ideas
trying to help the government to
understand what the broader political
implications of what they were doing was
and really just frankly learning a lot I
mean these these are really great ways
to learn and I moved from there to to
Brookings which is a big think tank in
Washington and I spent several years
there and at Brookings where I mostly
worked on
us-european relations I was able also to
get really involved in sort of
democratic foreign policy circles and to
work on campaigns for first for John
Kerry
and then for Barack Obama as a sort of
foreign policy adviser there are you
know dozens or even hundreds of these in
a u.s. presidential campaign but they
really give you some insight into the
way that foreign policy plays out in the
campaign and they just give you access
to the people and to the to the process
of a political campaign and so that was
quite helpful and after I had I'd signed
up to work for Barack Obama early in his
2008 campaign early in 2007 because US
presidential campaigns are essentially
endless and I did that because not
because I preferred him really to
Hillary Clinton but because I found him
to be interesting and because the
Hillary Clinton campaign was extremely
crowded as one as one of my friends put
it I'm tired of being in the same room
having the same arguments with everybody
that I used to argue with in the Clinton
administration sounds on my Facebook
yeah I think the Clinton campaign is a
little bit about the Facebook feed its
people who've been together for too long
kind of a problem that she's had for a
long time and the Obama campaign was
just much more exciting it really wasn't
philosophically different I would say
but it had a real different kind of
energy to it I thought and when they
asked me to be an adviser I said sure
why not I didn't expect him to win not
even sure I wanted him to win in terms
of Mike because you know it was pretty
happy with the think tank and the idea
of going into government was quite scary
to me and when contrary to my plans he
won which really was a huge shock I
still haven't quite gotten over it I am
I went into the I went in and worked at
the State Department as first as an
adviser to the Assistant Secretary of
State for European affairs who
had been a colleague of mine at
Brookings and had been the guy that
brought me into the campaign and then on
the policy planning staff where I worked
pretty closely with with Hillary Clinton
and with her big advisor Jake Sullivan
and you know that was incredible I mean
it was working in government at least in
the US government is really interesting
amazing even it's horrible I would have
to say it's I always compare it to a
like a car wreck you know it's like
horrible and tragic and unavoidable but
you cannot take your eyes off of it you
can't stop watching because it is really
fascinating and you learn a tremendous
amount some things that you really never
wanted to know about how government
works about how policy works and even
about how human nature works and it has
really informed my my subsequent work I
think it's had a greater sort of I don't
think I actually accomplished almost
anything and even the things that I
accomplished I'm not sure they were a
good idea but I think I learned more
from that experience than any other
experience I've had arguably it's made
me a bit too cynical but I do think that
everybody should should do that for at
least a few years just to sort of test
their assumptions and to understand what
the what I call the policymaking dilemma
is the pressures that the policymakers
are under I feel as if people who've
never been in government don't and
frankly quite a few have don't really
have an appreciation for the variety of
pressures and the types of constraints
that policymakers typically operate
under the sort of you outside is oh
these people have a lot of power they
can do anything they want the view from
the inside is that you're barage from a
hundred different directions and you
have incredibly little freedom of action
and that people are telling you things
making recommendations to you that you
already know
and have already rejected or already
trying to do but you can't and you can't
do anything about it and that's
incredibly frustrating and I think as
what I've tried to do particularly since
I left is to try to understand the
pressures that those people are under
and to talk to them in a way that they
can you know that they certainly that
challenges them you need to challenge
them but also that understands the
constraints that they face do you think
looking back at the Trump campaign with
phrases like drain the swamp do you
think that actually public trust in
politicians as and especially in
Washington has actually decreased
significantly no I was I always find
that to be a strange question because I
can't remember a time when people had
trusts in politicians so it hasn't
really decreased it's always been
terrible but you just got even worse
where someone openly refers to
Washington as a swamp and everyone goes
yeah okay well not everyone but but
there's some people who voted for him
know people have been doing that my
entire adult life you know it is it is
classic certainly among American
politicians to run against Washington
they people have been doing that at
least since Ronald Reagan probably
before and to run as an outsider to run
as an anti-establishment figure think
about this george w bush when he ran for
president in 2000 rinna gainst
washington ran as an anti-establishment
figure he positioned himself that way
and people bought it in the twenty Lurie
clinton tried to run as an outsider he
was the vice president everybody does
this too they don't succeed sometimes
they don't succeed very often they don't
succeed george w bush did succeed is
positioning himself an outsider so
almost anything is possible you know
Donald Trump
what what makes Donald Trump an outsider
he's a billionaire he's been hobnobbing
with all of these establishment figures
for 20 years he's certainly an [ __ ]
so I don't know that what makes him an
outsider but he's he he took the same
rhetoric I think that the distinction to
me made in the 2016 election is that
there is a there is a certain let's say
oligarchy in both parties which you know
in the United States I think like any
country is is a sort of combination
between democracy and oligarchy and I
think this is actually kind of necessary
because you can't run a country without
an elite you know you all people are
always running against the elite but you
never but you don't actually ever run a
country without an elite you just
replaced the current one that you have
and the United States has had for a long
time a system of competitive elites who
who run the country in alternation which
is a good you know reasonably good way
of keeping them honest but certainly can
be frustrating to people who aren't in
either of those elites Donald Trump did
something in the 2016 campaign which was
very new it wasn't running against
Washington that's the oldest trope in
the book it was avoiding having any sort
of debt or homage to the oligarchy of
his party he ran against not just the
Democratic Party not just against
Washington he ran against the Republican
Party he ran against their control of
the system and that was never possible
before not because you couldn't make the
the political message but because you
couldn't get the money and get the
backing and the endorsement of key
institutions like the media and the
expert community like I am part of and
he was able to evade that system in the
first instance by being incredibly
wealthy but maybe more importantly by in
the second instance being already a
celebrity and not really needing their
endorsement he had his own brand he
didn't need the Republican brand I mean
typically if you start off
as as a new presidential candidate you
need to convince the public that you're
not a lunatic and in the way the way
that you convinced the public that
you're not a lunatic is people that they
already know not to be lunatics come out
and say no this guy's got a pretty
interesting campaign he's good
Donald Trump didn't need to do that not
because he's not a lunatic but because
people already knew who he was this is
very very rare in American politics that
someone comes from nowhere I think it's
perhaps the the future of America that's
what I was about to ask you do you think
it's Donald Trump's all the way in from
here like is it gonna be Oprah Winfrey
Kanye West this is you know what is that
what's gonna happen I think that Donald
Trump has demonstrated if we really
needed any demonstration the incredible
power of celebrity and social media has
only accentuated this and that I think
we should expect people are always
asking me who is the Democratic
candidate for 2020 and you know you can
you can come up with 30 or 40 different
possibilities I think that there's also
a very good chance that the Democratic
candidate is someone that we have never
heard of or at least never considered as
a democratic yeah yeah yeah they
probably have headlined in this club and
you know I think that that kind of
celebrity that kind of non politician
that kind of person who has a rapport
with the public that the public knows
who they are that they don't need to go
through the party oligarchy or through
the expert community that they have no
problem either raising money or just
already having money and that they don't
need any of the sort of existing groups
to say well this guy's okay this guy's
not a lunatic this guy's plans make
sense I think that could be the future
of American politics it's it's
fascinating to note that when you look
at almost all of the last several
presidents sort of including george w
bush they they've really basically come
from nowhere they've they've been people
who not only haven't had much of a
political record but have succeeded
because they haven't had
record when people were advising Barack
Obama on whether he should run for
president in 2006 7 when he'd only you
know just been in politics for like as a
senator for a couple of years they were
saying well you know maybe you should
get maybe you should you know get more
experience get more into Washington know
people more and he had the insight to
understand that actually the only time
he could run for president was in his
first term as Senator and if you look at
the 2016 Republican primary what you see
is that every new senator basically ran
for president you know the Republican
side in 2016 because they realized that
if they didn't they would have too much
of a record too much experience to run
for president it only counts against you
these days and I think that future
presidential candidates are going to
understand that already our
understanding that so you know I don't
know if Oprah wants to be President I
know that she couldn't be worse than
Donald Trump haha I don't think she
knows really anything about being
president but I don't think that it's
really important to have a lot of sort
of of the typical experience that that
we generally associate with presidents
to be a good president I do think that
you need to have a few qualities that
Donald Trump really lacks which is you
know listening to people the capacity to
learn a basis of good of good judgment
and a moral Center those things would be
nice you know Oprah Winfrey may have
those maybe some other celebrities will
I'm not you know alterable opposed I
mean obviously as an expert and as
someone who spent my life trying to
educate myself about these stuff it's
very sad for me to say well you know you
don't really need to be an expert to be
president but I think that's fine
what I'm hoping for is that we can find
someone even if they're even if they're
a celebrity who is willing to learn who
has
judgment who has a moral core who has
something that they wanted to achieve
what I don't know is how to assess those
things by someone's music house so the
headline set angel yeah yeah and so I
mean I ask you does what Oprah Winfrey
have those things she might I don't know
terrifies me okay you are particularly
success whether you're a musician or an
actor how does that qualify you to go
and negotiate with North Korea about the
disarmament of their nuclear weapons
yeah look I shouldn't tell you this as
an expert as someone who does
International Relations it doesn't
qualify you to do that but it's not
important to be able to do that as
president it the president has a lot of
people that can do that for him that can
help him do that that can instruct him
on how to do that the government
Washington is full of people like this
they're all over the place
honestly I could I could assemble six
for you and in in a in an hour we could
have a pickup basketball game about
North Korea well I think you some of the
Avengers it's not anywhere near that
interesting nobody has unfortunately but
what what a president needs is not an
ability to negotiate not information
knowledge about North Korea we could
teach him that in an afternoon he needs
us enough self-confidence to reach out
Trump too much to the experts no Donald
Trump doesn't have that I mean I think
that this is a fundamental problem one
of the ways that you can tell that
Donald Trump is deeply insecure and
lacks the necessary self-confidence to
be a good president is the way he keeps
telling you how great he is I'm sure
that you guys probably went to high
school and however familiar with this
type yeah right no I mean Oh someone
who's truly self-confident is someone
who is able to listen and take advice
and not feel like it diminishes
temperature you know I we you were
saying earlier that that Hillary Clinton
has become very toxic and I think
there's definitely some truth to that in
American politics but one of the things
that gave me great comfort in working
with her and in voting for her later as
president even though I often disagreed
with her on key issues was that she was
someone who was confident enough in her
intellect and in her capacity to listen
to people that she disagreed with to
take argument seriously to wrestle with
ideas in a way that was that was open to
to change you didn't usually change your
mind because generally speaking she was
smarter than you were and she generally
felt like she was right but she but she
listened and she occasionally changed
her mind and she had a basic good
judgment and a basic moral core and I
think that that's what presidents need
and I don't rule out a celebrity having
those kinds of things if you think about
Ronald Reagan he because I should add
something else that a president needs
he's really the ability to communicate
with the public and you know I can't do
that
I think as this interview is probably
already proven and you know I think that
that's a real political skill which a
lot of very very smart very very expert
people simply don't have it has frankly
nothing to do with knowing what the
right thing to do in North Korea is and
you know I think people like Ronald
Reagan and Donald Trump are very good at
that and that's and I think maybe
celebrities in general could be good at
that that's probably how they became
celebrities but what we're gonna need to
do if we're gonna have people like that
communicators as president people who
can get who can get whose communication
skills allow them to get elected we're
gonna need to be able to be able to
forge a an alliance if you will with an
expert governing class that can help the
communicators govern Reagan did that
pretty well Donald Trump isn't doing
that at all
he's not even trying it doesn't
recognize that he needs to and I think
that's the real
struggle that we'll have is if we're
gonna have government by celebrity or
government by a famous person how are we
gonna create a system where they can
access expertise and not feel diminished
[Music]
so here you are in the UK talking about
and advising people about for and
researching foreign relations I saw an
interview that you did with channel 4 I
think was news night and one of the
things you said I think you mentioned
you got a lot of pushback on was the
Britain is a medium level power where
well what is your view of Britain's role
in the world today yeah look I should
say uh in starting off that I live in
the United Kingdom and I do that for a
reason I really like it it's a great
country it's a wonderful place to live
and it's got a great future so I don't
mean to be disparaging of it when I say
you know get real you know I mean the
Donald Tusk is famous for saying there
are two kinds of countries in Europe
those countries that realize that their
small countries and those countries that
don't and the United Kingdom is clearly
one that doesn't realize that it is that
it is a medium-sized power it's odd
there is this very strange schizophrenia
about this if you look at government
policy if you look at the way that the
United Kingdom has been reducing its
military budget the way that the United
Kingdom has been withdrawing a lot of
its influence in the world you see a
very strong recognition that the United
Kingdom needs to redefine its
relationship with the world and and
think of itself as a medium power which
can certainly punch above its weight but
needs to relate very well with its
neighbors and with some of its key
partners in order to function in the
world but yet if you look at the sort of
politics in Britain if you look at the
way people speak about the United
Kingdom it sounds like it's 1890 I'm
enid there's there's a sort of idea of
you know what did they call it Empire
2.0 every third movie
seems to be about Dunkirk or about 1940
you know these were great times I
understand that and that some amazing
things were accomplished but did win the
war yeah yeah that was great
I think we can all take some credit
let's just say that you know it was it
was good that the war was won I think we
can all agree on that but it was kind of
a while ago the world has moved on even
if the movies have not and I think there
is a there is a new reality and in this
new reality the United Kingdom still has
enormous strengths but it cannot be the
United Kingdom of old it needs to
understand that it has that it is a
medium power in a difficult and cruel
world and that means it needs to seek
very think very carefully about its
alliances about its international
positioning that means there can be no
spirit of Dunkirk for 2018 because
because the United Kingdom cannot
function alone and that means it needs
to think very hard about the role that
its European partners play and its
Security and Prosperity and the role of
the United States plays in its security
and prosperity and I feel as if that
debate here is very often submerged in
an imperial nostalgia which doesn't
really help anybody so in a roundabout
way you're basically saying breaks it
was a mistake I hope that that wasn't a
roundabout way of saying yeah I mean
brexit is a spectacular mistake in my
view it is very much turkeys voting for
Christmas and I you know I think there
is a good possibility that with a lot of
clever statesmanship on the on both the
European and the and the British side
that it can be only not not much worse
than it was before
that's a good possibility but there are
really only downsides and it could be
terrible and it's all completely
unnecessary
stupid because I think you know a proper
debate in the pre referendum period
would have would have told some people
some harsh realities about the world
today and I think actually even the
remain side was really unwilling to do
that they were unwilling and you know I
understand why in political
communication it's not good to tell
people you have to do this
and that's again you know why I'm not a
good politician I think this interview
really demonstrates that but but the
fact of the matter is and you know I'm a
fact of the matter is guy Britain needs
its European partners it needs them even
because the United States isn't a
reliable enough partner and this idea of
you know the going back to the Empire or
going back to a special relationship
which has never really existed or
certainly not existed in the way that
the British think of it is is a fantasy
I wanted to ask you about Trident
Britain's nuclear weapons before I do I
just want to say this table is this
microphone is rather very sensitive so
when you tap the table it's out of the
listeners like Trident has been since
long so sorry about that to launch a
curious you talk about it cruel and
harsh world I mean in the world where
Russia is running around doing the
things that it's doing and with the
backup words nuclear weapons I mean
Russia is very clear about that they the
Russian regime says we are powerful
because we have nukes we have a lot of
nukes right what do you make of the
debate or the conversations around
Trident Jeremy Corbyn the labor leader
in this country has said that he wants
to get rid of it other people saying
this would be ridiculous what do you
think would be the impact for Britain of
losing its nuclear deterrent well I I
think it would be a bad idea for Britain
to lose its nuclear deterrent overall I
think a nuclear deterrent particularly
for a mature country like Britain is is
broadly speaking a good idea and it does
you know it does sort of prevent the
worst possible catastrophes I I would
say however that particularly when you
look at Trident and when you look at the
way that Britain is maintaining its
nuclear to turn it is it
ordinarily expensive it is or it is a
massive drain on the British defense
budget on a certain level the British
defense budget and almost a lot of the
British public purse is becoming just
focused if you frankly if you look at if
you look at British public spending
these days it basically looks like the
NHS and the nuclear deterrent I mean
that's a slight exaggeration pensions as
well of course yes and I think that what
what the British need to do is I
certainly wouldn't advise getting rid of
the nuclear to turn I would be thinking
very hard about whether Trident is the
right way to do that and I would be
thinking very hard about how they can
better cooperate with their partners
right I mean on with the nuclear
deterrent I mean the French or have the
French have a nuclear deterrent which is
also weighing them down the Germans
aren't participating in it at all but of
course they're benefitting from it and
that's true of the rest of Europe and
you know the the great insight about the
European Union particularly European
Union foreign policy is that basically
you guys all want the same thing you're
not really competing with each other
which is a sort of historical miracle at
this point and so it makes sense to
combine your efforts when you're medium
sized countries in a harsh and cruel
world but Europe isn't doing that I mean
one of the points you made in the
nautical that you wrote recently you
were talking about Iran and we'll get to
that in a second but one of the points
you made is actually Europe is divided
quite often against itself and countries
will seek the help of America against
other European countries within Europe
so while we're not cooperating isn't not
wise for Britain to hold on to its
ability to deter others particularly
because once the other thing that would
happen if Britain was to give away
Trident would essentially to put it very
crudely you become America's [ __ ] even
more because you don't have your own
ability to you know together no I
wouldn't advocate I would agree I
wouldn't advocate that Britain should
get rid of its nuclear deterrent I'm not
sure about the Trident aspect of it
a submarine-launched deterrent like that
like they have is extremely expensive so
I think my only point is that in
maintaining a nuclear deterrent which I
think it should do in part not to be
America's [ __ ] but really not to be
anybody's [ __ ] well yeah because
because being a [ __ ] sucks I'm glad I
brought that up you've really run with
it yeah well this is a sort of rule of
international politics I think that they
they do need to look very carefully at
at ways of doing that more cheaply one
way might be thinking about other
mechanisms besides trident another way
might be cooperating with European
partners on like a last based thing if
it was land-based or air based yeah yeah
I mean you know the thing about a
nuclear weapon I think people get very
involved in the sort of intricacies well
you know what see launched weapon is
very hard to find and it's very
survivable second strike blah blah blah
you know you know you know luxurious
world it would be good to think about
all of these things but actually if you
look at the history of nuclear weapons
it doesn't matter that much the
important thing is that you have them
and then people think you might be able
to use them and people don't take a lot
of risks when it comes to nuclear
weapons there was a sort of that's kind
of understand yeah so you know there's a
lot of focus in United States about
stewardship does the nuclear weapon work
you know if I was an opponent of the
United States know something well you
know it's not clear that America's
nuclear weapons really work a hundred
percent of the time we can trade there
only 60 70 percent reliable let's invade
and see how that works no people don't
think that way
so also yeah I think a deterrent ISM is
important I think we underestimate how
easy it is to create a deterrent with
nuclear weapons that's both the great
and the horrible thing about them and so
Trident is a very very sophisticated
system submarine-launched ballistic
missiles are very sophisticated system
they do provide an extraordinarily
survivable deterrent and that's
impressive and during the Cold War it
was the sort of jewel in the crown
the American nuclear Trident triad
excuse me um but but I'm not really sure
it's necessary for the kind of nuclear
deterrent that that the United Kingdom
both needs and can afford and the
embassy can you just give us a little
bit of a background as to why that is so
inflammatory sure I mean it's a big
question I accept that yeah you want me
to go back to yeah I mean everything in
Israel starts with the Bible but but I
won't go back that far I think the issue
is - is the central question of the
israeli-palestinian conflict is the City
of Jerusalem I mean and it is biblical
it is for all of the three monotheistic
religions Judaism Christianity and Islam
a sort of central and holy city and to
go there is to sort of wallow in the in
the incredible history of those
religions in that city and in their
conflict over centuries and millennia
it's quite incredible and so it is
particularly for the Israelis and the
Palestinians a city which is sort of
deep in their emotional heart deep in
their historical heart they both have
historical claims to that city which go
back millennia and the when the when
Israel was created in 1948 the the city
was divided not between the Israelis and
the Palestinians interestingly between
the Israelis and the Jordanians and
Israel had West Jerusalem and Jordan had
East Jerusalem and East Jerusalem is
where the Temple Mount is which is the
holiest site both for in Jerusalem for
both for the Jews and for
Muslims because it's where the Al Aqsa
mock mosque is and the in the 1967 war
the six-day war the Israelis seized all
of Jerusalem and the Jordanians
relinquished their claim to the
Palestinians and so since the since the
Israeli occupation in 1967 there has
been an effort by the Israelis to
establish in the mind of the entire
international community that Jerusalem
is the undivided capital of Israel they
they have not annexed the West Bank they
have they they did not annex Gaza which
they which they also took in the 67 war
but they have annexed East Jerusalem
they have claimed that they will always
rule over this and the question of of
how Jerusalem will play in what's called
the two-state solution the idea that
there will be a Palestinian state next
to a next to Israel at a certain point
has been the central one of the central
questions in the israeli-palestinian
negotiations going back to at least Camp
David in the 1970s and so when Trump
decides to move I mean I guess I should
add that the US Congress which has
always been even more pro-israeli than
US presidents passed a bill in in the
1990s in 1995 saying that the United
States recognizes Jerusalem as the
capital and we'll move the embassy there
and presidents have always since that
time waived that requirement in the bill
saying that it wasn't it wasn't in the
interests of the United States and the
interests of peace in in in the Middle
East to move the to move the US Embassy
to Jerusalem previous presidents in
other words knew how inflammatory this
would be and have avoided doing it yeah
well it's not just that it would be
inflammatory you know I think the
obviously there's been a lot of violence
in the last few days but
that that's not the central question
because there's always violence in the
Middle East and and if you want to do
something anything you have to you have
to you you will very often create
Italy's short term violence it's the
nature of the region I think you know
it's very important that it'll be
inflammatory but the more central
question is does it in the longer term
push toward peace and here I think US
presidents have felt that if you want to
bring Israel and Palestine together you
need to be able to coerce both of them
right you need to be able to have
carrots and sticks for both of them and
a critical carrot and/or stick against
the Israelis in creating a negotiation
is the status of Jerusalem
so typically American American officials
would say well you know we're gonna hold
the status of Jerusalem tell the end to
seal the deal
because that's what the Israelis most
want and and it's just a it's just a
tenant of negotiations that you don't
play your strongest card at the
beginning you play them at the end you
know Donald Trump I don't think he does
it's not that he doesn't understand that
exactly it's that he doesn't seem to
care he's interested in making a big
splash he's interested in having an
impact immediately long term for him as
next Tuesday and so he doesn't really
seem to care as far as I can tell
because I mean you could say he doesn't
know but but at least a hundred people
have told him directly and he either
doesn't take it in or doesn't care and
so I don't think that this has really
furthered the cause of peace and not
just because of the immediate violence
which is bad enough but also because it
makes the structure of the negotiation a
lot harder you know having said that and
maybe that weighs on Donald Trump it
wasn't going well anyway
[Laughter]
and it's not really clear that he
spoiled anything because it's not clear
that there was anything to spoil but you
know I think you know in a situation
that appears hopeless like the
israeli-palestinian negotiations it
probably doesn't make sense to just make
it all the more hopeless in the in
because you want to have a good photo
opportunity and I think that that's what
he's done so you're saying that the
decision to move the embassy was based
entirely on ego yeah on ego and on
domestic politics I think frankly you
can you can trace every Donald Trump
foreign policy decision thus far to some
combination of ego and domestic politics
because he he isn't really interested in
foreign policy per se beyond immigration
questions and maybe international trade
questions doesn't really have anything
he wants to accomplish in the long term
he's not trying to create a specific
role for the United States in the world
he's not really trying to reshape the
world in any according to any sort of
ideology or image Donald Trump has one
very very clear ideology and it's it's
it's the greater magnificence of
Donald's from
[Music]
picking up on that then would you make
of Donald Trump led withdrawal from
their own nuclear deal can you first of
all just for anyone who doesn't know
what it is including me and Francis to a
large extent what was the Iran nuclear
deal what still is around nuclear deal
and why did Donald Trump decide to pull
out of it
so the Iran nuclear deal which is the
technical term for it is the jcpoa the
joint comprehensive plan of action
sounds good yeah yeah
anything with an acronym like that must
be good yeah it was a deal between
actually seven countries what they
called the p5 plus one which is all of
the permanent members of the UN Security
Council which is the US Russia China
France and Britain plus Germany and then
those six with how to deal with Iran
essentially and the essential deal was a
very simple one really the Iranians
agreed to freeze their nuclear program
to dismantle their your their nuclear
enrichment capacity and to submit to a
very very intrusive regime of
inspections to verify that and the
international community those seven
countries six countries excuse me agreed
to give them to relieve the economic
sanctions and that had been placed in
against Iran and to give them some
economic benefits so that their economy
could could get back on track this was a
really really controversial deal
particularly in the United States and
Iran and the the substance of the
complaint at least on the US side was
that that this had not addressed arraign
Iran's other nefarious activities in in
the region Iran is involved in a lot of
civil wars in the region in places like
Syria and yeah
and and Iraq and it hadn't addressed
Iran's ballistic missile capability and
that Iran was still a very bad actor you
know the response to this from the
officials that created the deal was yeah
that's true you know one thing at a time
what we did in this deal was addressed
the nuclear program and that's really
important for her for all the reasons
that we that we talked about in the way
that nuclear weapons but they also say
that there was cash involved the West
was actually giving a round cap that's
not true a frequent theme in in
responding to Donald Trump but what what
was happening was that a lot of the cat
a lot of Iran's money had been frozen in
western bank accounts as a result and
part of the Revolution and part of the
sanctions and some of the Iran's own
money was released back to them so I
would I would assert that there's a big
difference between giving Iran cash and
giving them back their own money which
hasn't which had never belonged to
anybody else but yeah I mean Iran the
intent of this deal going beyond cash
was to give Iran economic benefits so if
we assume that there is a rational
element to Donald Trump what is the
ration and I know it's an assumption
what is the rationale for withdrawing
from this deal which prevents around
from developing nuclear weapons I can't
come up with a rationale I tried you
know I think that there is there is a
real effort by a lot of people to
construct a strategic narrative around
what Donald Trump does I guess because
it just makes us feel better about the
world right okay well I think what he's
trying to do is this and he's got this
plan and the word rational why does she
think it's bad I think he thinks that
the deal is bad because it allows Iran
to engage in all of these other
activities because Obama made it
and he wants to undo the legacy I mean
frankly if you look at what the
president is apparently going to do
seems to be about to do in North Korea
he's probably not going to conclude a
deal as favorable as the Iranian nuclear
deal with the North Koreans but we'll
have the essential distinction that it
will not be concluded by Barack Obama
which American foreign policy is now
operating yeah I mean look that's the
level at which Donald Trump is operating
you can certainly if you are or let's
say John Bolten Donald Trump's national
security adviser you can have a more
strategic rationale but the only way
that you can understand that rationale
is this if you are moving in one way or
another toward a policy of regime change
in Iran john bolton has been very clear
that he doesn't think that we can ever
have an effective deal or ever have a
responsible actor in iran as long as
this regime is in charge of iran and
that means pretty clearly that if you
want to solve this problem you have to
move toward some policy that's going to
get you to regime change and in that in
that way obviously you would not want
the nuclear deal what you would want is
an international coalition that was
frustrating nuclear weapons to create
enemies against iran you'd want to go
back to the to the days of 2014 where
everybody was allied against the
iranians and so that makes a certain
amount of sense it's very clear that's
not what donald trump was trying to do
he ran on getting the United States out
of the Middle East not on fighting
another regime change war with a yet
stronger regime in the Middle East so I
don't think that's in his mind but that
is where his policy is is pushing us so
I mean what would you see as I mean
let's say that the that Trump has his
way what are going to be the long-term
implications do you think
well Trump will probably have his way
when it comes to the Iranian nuclear
deal I don't think that it really holds
together without without the United
States and I'm very nervous about the
the implications I think look I always
say i bout the policymakers dilemma
thinking and so I always try to get into
the mind of the people so let's just
imagine for a moment that you're the
Iranian national security adviser which
is you know probably a tough job you get
something wrong it's not you know just
fired right yeah yeah yeah it has many
many disadvantages I think the media is
even tougher
so you're the Iranian national security
adviser and one day you have this you
have this nuclear deal and one day the
most powerful country on earth with a
president who seems you know withdraws
from it tells the entire world that
you're evil and basically signals that
they're coming to get you which is what
you know Donald Trump hasn't precisely
done that but many of his subordinates
have done that in ways which you don't
have to be paranoid to be afraid of what
would you do well you know I mean we
just discussed it in the case of the
United Kingdom you would develop nuclear
weapons immediately that's exactly what
I would do because basically they've
been told that a country with the most
powerful military in the world is out to
get you so my suspicion will be that
over the next several months that the
Iranians will turn back toward creating
a nuclear program just because that's
what I would do oh I could be wrong
about that I don't really understand
what's going on in the Iranian regime I
know it's very contested but there were
a lot of people in Iran at the time the
nuclear deal was concluded and since
that have been saying exactly the
opposite of what the Donald Trump was
saying this is a bad deal for us we need
these nuclear weapons because if we
don't have them eventually they will
the Americans will come for us and so
this will verify everything that they
have been saying so they'll create
they'll they'll move toward that and
that will mean that the United States
and it's in Israel and Saudi Arabia will
try to resurrect the international
coalition against them I'm not sure if
they'll succeed in bringing back the
Europeans and the Russians and the
Chinese who might feel pretty burnt by
this but they might are at least succeed
in bringing back the Europeans and that
will try to try to create a lot of
economic pressure on Iran the first
phase in and in the typical sort of
American regime change script is you
create pressure on the regime you assert
that there is a Democratic opposition
which is just yearning to be breathe
free that works but is oppressed by the
regime there's always a degree of truth
to that but usually exaggerated and you
try to stimulate regime change from
within
sometimes by also having a program on
the side to to support the people who
want to do that within the country when
that doesn't work you start to you start
to up the to up the up the level of
empathy between both sides and to create
to create an a reason to have a greater
conflict so that you can devote more
American resources and more allied
resources to the struggle and you know
in the Iraq case that ended that was a
long that was a long period and that was
12 years basically from the first Gulf
War the Second Gulf War where these
dynamics were going on and that ended
with an American invasion I think an
American invasion of Iran is is very
very unlikely but a sort of long-term
conflict in which there's even force
used between the two of them is is
definitely possible because I think
there will be people in the United
States who will believe that regime
change is both necessary and possible if
we keep up the pressure for long enough
so it sounds to me like what you're
saying with Donald Trump is that
essentially the world's policeman is
withdrawing from the world to some
extent and you think there's going to be
more crime because of it no I wouldn't
say that's exactly what I'm saying
certainly not in the Iran case actually
um there and again this gets to the to
the confusion of Donald Trump Donald
Trump definitely ran on we don't want to
be the policemen all right yeah he
definitely said we don't want I'm not
interested in Middle Eastern Wars but
his policy and the policy of a lot of
his the the avowed policy a lot of a lot
of his subordinates including people
like John Bolton specifically to be the
policemen in places like the Middle East
and specifically to police the Iranian
regime so there's a huge contradiction
here right if you were going if you
didn't want to be the world's policemen
the nuclear deal was a great idea right
because it allows you to say well we've
dealt with a nuclear problem and there
are other problems with Iran but those
are easier to deal with and the
countries in the region can deal with
them or the Russians can deal with them
who cares we don't we only care about
nuclear weapons but once the nuclear
weapons are back on the table that is
really something which engages the
American public which engages American
security interests because we're
especially scared of nuclear weapons and
that brings you back in to the Middle
East you know does Donald Trump
understand this contradiction I have no
idea he doesn't really seem that
interested in it Donald Trump bless him
I wish I had this capacity he he doesn't
seem to care about consistency it's
probably what's made him a great
politician and so he is you know they
say that it that the mark of genius is
the ability to hold two contradictory
thoughts in your mind at the same time
and not go crazy Donald Trump could hold
dozens so in that sense he is a very
super genius is the best genius in the
world yeah there's something to that I
mean I have to say that that would keep
me awake at night
the idea that I was both trying to get
the United States out of the Middle East
and taking measures that would that seem
to be getting at States into greater
conflict with Iran his subordinates and
he has both types of subordinates are
struggling against these two issues and
so the result basically is confusion and
you can read a lot of different policies
into what the United States is doing if
you if you're focused on Iran you're
thinking he's trying to get in if you're
focused on Syria you're thinking he's
trying to get out and these things don't
really work well together but that's Don
Trump I think that's a fantastic place
to leave yeah we can do that uh constant
we always ask the final question Jeremy
so the final question is always in this
podcast what is the number one issue
that you think is incredibly important
that people simply aren't talking about
at the moment yeah I was struggling with
that issue because with that question
because from my perspective Jeremy
you've just given away a secret that we
we asked the question in advance and you
get a chance to prepare this shows thank
you sorry sorry to give away your secret
yeah no I actually had all of the
questions in advance we don't know yeah
no I think it is helpful to be able to
think about that and it was it's hard
from my perspective because I gotta feel
like I talk about everything all the
time and people are always saying to me
yeah we're not paying enough attention
to Chinese banks or something and I
Indian and then I go out and find 1,100
different articles on Chinese banks we
have a massive media environment we have
a massive expertise expert community
we're paying attention to virtually
everything some things don't have
political salience but that's really
about how the public receives them right
so it's not your friend gideon actually
made this point on this very show that
he wrote an article about something that
he thought was really important and then
no one read it yes so quite often even
if you are talking about something do
you think is essential no one really
cares
and then yeah what can you do about that
you can't really make people and frankly
a lot of times it's rational
I mean people shouldn't care about
things that don't affect them
immediately given that they have a lot
of things that do fact affect them
immediately and a limited bandwidth I
have to say that so too much to my mind
I'm always focused on what makes people
care about things and I say my
number-one frustration with the way that
people came up with the reasons that
people care about things is the lack of
statistical and probabilistic reasoning
in the public and if there were if you
know if I were Emperor of the world
that's a great way to start a statement
yeah yeah no I think it's mine too he's
somewhat closer but if I were emperor of
the world I would make everybody go to
statistics and probability class I would
then be overthrown immediately yes but
really one of the things that's
fascinating about the inability of
people like me to convince anyone
including I have faced an ad my mother
about my policy beliefs is that they
they don't reason according to large
numbers I find this to be both
fascinating and frustrating I guess if
you if you think about it there's a lot
of sort of evolutionary study on this
that people that we evolved in
communities of about a hundred and fifty
prior and so if you live in a community
of 150 people and somebody gets eaten by
a bear it makes sense for you to be
really really scared of bears and if the
neighboring village is harboring bears
it makes sense even for you to you know
have a problem with that neighbouring
village but if you live in a community
of 65 million which is the UK or seven
billion which is the world and somebody
gets eaten by a bear even if that person
gets eaten by the bear on live
television it doesn't make any sense for
you to be worried about bears you should
just go on with
your life as if no one was ever eaten by
a bear and that's but that is not what
we do when if when someone gets eaten by
a bear on live television we create a
war on bears oh and we invade countries
and so I'm obviously talking about
terrorism or anything else but I think
it's it exists on a whole bunch of
different issues if you're trying if
you're trying to tell people what to be
afraid of and what not to be afraid of
they don't understand what you're saying
because they don't understand what large
numbers mean is they don't understand
that it probably doesn't make sense to
go out and fight a war in Iraq or or
Syria to prevent terrorism back here
when you have much bigger problems and
in fact terrorism isn't much of a threat
because it looks so good on television
and I think that this is this sort of
lack of statistical and probabilistic
reasoning is one of the main problems
that we have in our public policy I have
no idea what to do about it because
we're not going to improve it but I do
think that it is the issue which people
are paying it is the sort of the problem
with our public discourse that people
are paying very little attention to
that's a really great point I'm going to
end the show before we let you go you
are on Twitter at jy Shapiro jy Shapiro
perfect I'm Constance and kissing at
Constance and Kissin failing human if
you enjoyed the show this week please
subscribe to us on YouTube follow us on
Twitter at trigger pod on Instagram as
well
on itunes on soundcloud we're gonna be
on pocket cast very soon so just follow
us subscribe to us and we'll see you in
about a week's time thanks for watching
thank you
[Music]